this is what's called electronic
tribalism that we can remove all these
interpretive filters and structures and
methods the representative of the
Parliament the election all of that can
be done away with him that we can
actually and they hate that was very
interesting in the last presidential
campaign I don't know if you picked up
on it but only Perot spoke for this you
know he has this idea of these
electronic town meetings
well of course per row represents a a
not mainstream point of view from the
point of view of the Republicans and the
Democrats they both just piled onto that
they hate that the idea of real
democracy is is threatening to the
politicians of this country as it is to
the Chinese leadership I mean they do
not want the will of the people to be
expressed but I think as we cohere into
a single organism there will be less and
less need for these eighteenth-century
institutions but we have put in place
and maintained with the power of the gun
but people say what should be done what
should we do besides take psychedelics
and I'd say you cannot escape the media
you cannot escape the internet you
cannot escape our dilemma you have two
choices you can consume or you can
produce and that's it and the people who
consume our lost souls and we all
consume and in those moments when we
consume we are lost souls we we need to
produce and what we produce is art art
is the greatest era of art in the
history of the human race is dawning
right now
if we produce images and text from the
heart we will we will compete with these
very large network channels called
capitalism communism so forth and so on
in a sense one way to think about the
Internet is it's a 40 million Channel TV
hookup 40 million and huh and so no one
need feel isolated and isolation has
traditionally been a political tool for
disempowering people if you can make
people feel isolated you can make them
shut up but never before in history have
people been able to have a dialog in
real time with their own cultural
database and the quality of decision is
directly dependent upon the quality of
the information upon which the decisions
are based and in the past good quality
information is very hard to come by the
mass media is for the peasants well now
that's all changing sitting without
telephone lines in Hawaii at the
keyboard of my computer I have better
intelligence than Stansfield Turner had
when he was director of the CIA for
Jimmy Carter and I'm Joe nobody you know
earth citizen one so that shows you how
quickly the quality of information is
improving what you do with this is of
course has always been an individual
dilemma
[Music]